part d
let p sub four of x be the fourth degree
taylor polynomial for f about x equals
zero using information from the graph of
y is equal to the absolute value of the
fifth derivative of of f of x
shown above and that's the graph right
over here
i put it on the side to save space show
that the absolute value of the
difference between the polynomial the
fourth degree polynomial value at
one-fourth and the function evaluated at
one-fourth is less than one over three
thousand so this is this seems like
quite an interesting problem here so
first let's just think about what
they're asking they're asking for the
difference between the polynomial and
the function evaluated one-fourth in
other words they're asking us to they're
asking us to bound the error the error
of the function approximation at
at at x is equal to 1 4. so let me draw
a little graph here just so we can
visualize it a little better so that's
our y-axis and let me draw it like this
so this is our y-axis and this is our
x-axis and our function let's say our
function looks something like this our
polynomial is centered at zero our
fourth degree polynomial is centered at
zero
and so it'll be equal to the function at
zero and then it'll become probably a
worse approximation as we get further
and further away from zero and what
they're saying is let's bound how bad of
an approximation that is when x is equal
to 1 4. so if we say that this is x is
equal to one-fourth right over here
they're saying look take the value of
the polynomial at one-fourth subtract
from that the value of the function at 1
and then take the absolute value and
then that will essentially give us the
the absolute value of the error or that
will give us the absolute value of the
remainder or give us or give us the
distance between the two functions there
and they want us to bound they want us
to bound that distance
now to do this problem there is
something that you just kind of have to
know and i prove it in another in
another series of videos two videos i
think it took me in the khan academy
calculus playlist if you do a search for
bounded or error or approximation or
taylor you should probably find it and
that there's a general there's a general
idea here
a general idea which we've proved that
if you have some function so i'm just
i'm going to show the general so if you
have some function f of x
if you have some function f of x and
that you have some polynomial
approximation of it
of degree n some polynomial
approximation of degree n and let's say
that this polynomial approximation is
centered at a in our particular case a
is zero so that you're centered at a so
we could write we could say this is this
is about a
it's an approximation about x equals a
we can bound the error so let me let me
first define this error function here
sometimes it's called a remainder so we
could say the error function
for the nth degree polynomial about a
the nth degree taylor polynomial
approximation about a it will be a
function of x so for any other x that
you pick what will this error be
is equal to the difference between these
two things you could say it's f of x
minus that or that minus f of x but let
me just write it this way this is equal
to
equal to f of x
minus the polynomial approximation of x
and if you want to take the absolute
value of this that's equal to absolute
value of that and if you're taking
absolute values then you can switch the
order so this is the same thing as the
absolute value of the polynomial
approximation at x minus
minus f of x so the thing that you just
need to know
is we can bound this we can bound this
if
if we know some properties about the n
plus one so this is the nth degree
approximation if we know some properties
about the n plus one derivative of f
so if
so if we know
if we know
if we know that the n plus one
derivative the n plus one derivative of
f
is less than or equal to some
maximum value in particular the absolute
value of the n plus one derivative of f
is less than or equal to some we could
call this some maximum value over
over the interval over over x is in the
interval between a
and
sum b
where b is greater than a
where
b
is greater than a
then
we can make the statement then we can
make the statement and this is once
again something that i prove in that
video i think i call it the boundedness
of the error remainder for taylor
approximation something like that then
we know
that
that the error function the error
function at any given x
for that where x is greater than or
eight or let me say this in particular
is any given x that's part of this
interval where x is part of this
interval between a and b is going to be
less than or equal to
is going to be less than or equal to m
times
x
minus a to the n plus 1 power
over
n plus one so this is the thing that you
really have to know kind of ahead of
time to be able to do this problem it
would be it would be nearly impossible
in the time constraints of the ap exam
to prove this from first principles i
encourage you to watch that video so you
can understand how this proof happens
from first principles but going into the
ap exam
based on the facts that this did show up
in the 2011 exam it's probably good to
know this property to know how to bound
it and this is clearly what they're
asking for because they're giving us we
know what we know what so we know what
the fourth we know what p sub 4 is p sub
4 of x it's up to the fourth degree term
of the polynomial approximation of f
about zero in part b we got all the way
to the sixth degree term so if you want
to go just to the fourth degree term
this is what p sub four is so this is
one plus
x squared over two
plus x to the fourth over fourth so we
know that and we wanna bound we want to
bound this thing right over here we want
to bound this thing over here so if we
can find if we can find an m
so this is the fourth degree polynomial
this is the fourth degree error that
we're talking about in this case
let me write this way the this is the
nth error in the general case but we
want to bound the fourth degree error so
if we want to bound the fourth degree
error
so we can say the fourth degree error
at b
and in this case we're going to say or
at 1 4 i should say not b i never
mentioned a b before i mentioned the b
when i prove it
the fourth degree error at 1 4 is going
to be less than or equal to i i didn't
mention a b here so if you take this to
be 1 4 and 1 4 is part of that interval
so you can apply it here so the fourth
the the fourth degree error i guess you
could say at 1 4 is going to be less
than or equal to some m
times b
i should say 1 4 minus a
1 4 minus a a in this in our particular
case for this problem is a 0. so 1 4
minus 0 is just 0 to n to the
n to the n plus 1 power so this is
this this is the fourth degree
polynomial n is four so the n plus one
power is the fifth power
all of that over all of that over and
sorry this was supposed to be n plus one
all of that over n plus one factorial so
this is going to be over
over 5 factorial don't want to confuse
it this was all of that is over n plus 1
n plus 1 factorial so all of this is
over 5 factorial
so we can make this statement if we know
if we know
if
we know
that the fifth derivative the n plus one
derivative if we know that the fifth
derivative of f
is less than or equal to some value m
the absolute value of the fifth
derivative of f i should say is less
than or equal to some value at
some is less than or equal to some value
m over the interval over the interval
over the interval x is between 0 and 1
4. those are our a's and b's in this
particular case
so when you look at the graph and that's
exactly what they gave us they gave us
the graph of the absolute value of the
fifth derivative of x and 1 4 is sitting
right over here so this is 1 4. we don't
know exactly what what we hit over here
this looks like it's roughly i don't
know 31 or 32 but we know it's
definitely less than 40. we know it's
definitely less than 40 over the
interval between 0 and 1 4. so we can
pick m to be 40. so we can pick m
we can say that m is going to be 40. we
know that this is less than or equal to
40 over that interval so we can make
this statement and so we know that this
thing right over here is going to be
less because this over here is the same
as this over here we know that this is
less than let me write it all out
this is
and i know of people who got fives on
this exam without being able to do this
so don't stress out if this seems really
bizarre too this is really so they can
separate out who happen to know this
really so this
we can say
is based on this
this property we can say is less than or
equal to
40 times 1 4 to the fifth power
so this is 40 times 1 4 to the fifth
power so i could just say divided by 4
to the 5th power
times in the denominator here we have 5
factorial i'll just write it out 5 times
4 times 3 times 2 and we don't have to
write the 1 that doesn't change the
value and now we can simplify this we
can divide the numerator and the
denominator by four so this becomes ten
that just becomes a one we can divide it
by five this becomes a two that becomes
a one we can divide by one
that becomes a one oh sorry we can
divide by two that becomes a one that
becomes a one and you say that this
quantity over here is going to be equal
to
one
so let me write it
so all of this stuff is less than or
equal to
one
over four to the fifth over four to the
fifth
times three
four to the fifth
times three that's all we have left in
the denominator and so what is four to
the fifth you may or may not know you
can work it out by hand if you like but
four to the fifth is the same thing as 2
to the 10th power because 4 is 2 squared
2 to the 10th power if you're familiar
with computer science is 10 24 but you
could work it out yourself so this is
going to be this is less than or equal
to this is less than or equal to 10
10 24 times three so what is that that
is equal less than or equal to
less than or equal to one over
three oh what is this 72
3000 one over
3072. so this quantity right over here
is less than one over
3072. we know we know that for a fact
well if something is less than one over
3072 it's definitely going to be less
than one over three thousand one over
three thousand is a larger number it has
a smaller denominator that's definitely
less than or equal to
one over three thousand
and then we are done we've proven that
this is less than one over three
thousand we've proven that the error at
one fourth is less than one over three
thousand